this is an exciting day for us here at
CBS mornings as we welcome back
who's now a dad Vlad and his wife Marion
have spent the past few weeks soaking up
the love from their newborn bundle of
joy baby Celine oh glad we're so happy
to have you back and we want to hear all
about your first weeks as a I'm just
looking at these beautiful pictures that
I took with Marion and I'm still like
gobsmacked uh how beautiful our daughter
is um it's I was saying to you guys on
the text it's a good thing I love my job
and I love y'all because I did not want
to leave this morning
um but it's been incredible thank you
all first of all let me say thank you to
everybody on the show and everybody at
CBS News has been so supportive and
wonderful
um our fans our viewers guys I got
things like I got tons of gifts from our
viewers like yes I mean there's one
woman Susan guy if you're out there
Susan thank you for this like quilt that
she made for us and we use it yeah
handmade and we use it um it's been
incredible it's been really so Vlad in
the old days uh pre-children one is
afraid that they will not wake up in
time for a Morning Show because you have
to get up early but you had no trouble
getting no trouble no sleep at all I
have no trouble getting up because we
are I'm texting people at like two in
the morning like hey I was just looking
at something on YouTube like what are
you guys think and people are waking up
the next day they're like what like
what's going on what are you doing up oh
yeah well what are you doing up I mean
you're on a schedule we're on a schedule
every three hours she's getting fed uh
you know we're changing her every three
hours
um she's eating well she's growing and
it's actually remarkable to watch them
you guys you guys are all parents you
know it's remarkable the first time like
they turn their heads and they you see
their eyes like following you across the
room you know it's it or like what what
she does when she hears your voice yes I
know you're gonna I mean I can't it's
first day back I can't be crying on said
there's no crying on set today
um uh and you saw that song that we've
I'm so grateful we played song because
we do all these little videos yeah this
is me singing to her what is that uh
the Tavarez Heaven Must Be Missing an
angel because that's her theme song
Heaven her name means Heaven Celine so
that song Heaven Must Be Missing an
angel we've been playing we played for
her throughout the time that she was in
the womb box cello Suites performed by
Yo-Yo Ma and every night we play that
for her this kid's gonna be a genius
it's going to be a genius if you don't
you don't spoiler blad I'm sorry you
know my deepest apologies for saying you
did not need the wipe warmer yes but in
fact you are warming wipes for your baby
so we went on that shopping spree and it
was amazing and everything that we got
we we are using and it's been wonderful
all of your advice all of you guys have
been tremendous but Tony said you're not
gonna need the baby wipe warmer and I
just threw it in the cart anyway and the
first couple of nights she would scream
her head off anytime you put them cold
wipes on her booty and like nah and now
what and now vladimirian are using him
too yes
[Laughter]